- Vítej zpět u kurzu Porozumění kvantové
informaci a výpočtům.
Jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický ředitel
vzdělávání v IBM Quantum.
Toto je druhá lekce série. Pokud jsi ještě
nesledoval první lekci, určitě se na ni podívej.
Budeme přímo navazovat na to, o čem jsme mluvili
v první lekci, takže je důležité rozumět
tomu materiálu před začátkem této lekce.
Také věz, že série
obsahuje kromě videí i obsah učebnice, a odkaz
na obsah učebnice
najdeš v popisu videa. Toto je druhá lekce
první jednotky série.
První jednotka pokrývá základy
kvantové informace.
V předchozí lekci jsme mluvili o kvantové informaci v kontextu jednotlivých systémů, to znamená, že máme jeden
systém, který uchovává informaci,
a popisujeme, jak
funguje izolovaně.
Věnovali jsme poměrně dost
času klasické informaci, hlavně abychom stanovili referenční bod a zdůraznili matematické podobnosti
mezi kvantovou a klasickou informací.
Také jsme viděli, jak mohou být kvantové stavy reprezentovány vektory, konkrétně vektory s
komplexními číselnými složkami a eukleidovskou normou rovnou jedné,
a diskutovali jsme standardní
bázová měření a unitární operace.
V této lekci rozšíříme náš
pohled na více systémů, z nichž každý je schopen
uchovávat kvantovou informaci.
Nejde jednoduše o to říci, že každý jednotlivý systém
funguje tak, jak jsme diskutovali minule, v jistém smyslu je celek
větší než součet jeho částí, a to platí i pro
klasickou informaci, když jsou zapojeny pravděpodobnosti.
Více systémů může
vzájemně interagovat a mohou být spolu korelované
například, a v kvantovém kontextu to zahrnuje možnost,
že jsou systémy provázané, což je termín, který
možná již slyšel.
Provázanost je velmi
důležitý jev v kvantové informaci a budeme o ní mít ještě hodně co říct, jak série pokračuje.
Existuje však jednoduchý princip, který nám nabízí hodně opory pro přemýšlení o
kvantové informaci pro více systémů a její pochopení,
a to je, že vždy můžeme
vzít dva nebo více systémů a spojit je dohromady nebo je jen konceptuálně
považovat za celek
a pohlížet na ně, jako by tvořily
jeden složený systém.
A když takto uvažujeme o
složeném systému jako o jediném systému, uvědomujeme si, že musí být popsán způsobem, který je konzistentní
se vším, co jsme se naučili
v předchozí lekci o jednotlivých systémech.
Uvidíme, jak to funguje
a jak popis kvantové informace
pro více systémů přirozeně vychází z toho, jak to funguje pro jednotlivé systémy,
na základě tohoto jednoho principu. Zde je přehled lekce, který je náhodou totožný s přehledem předchozí lekce,
ale tentokrát se zaměříme
na více systémů, nikoli na jednotlivé systémy.
Stejně jako v předchozí lekci a ze stejných důvodů začneme
klasickou informací.
Opět uvidíme
velmi blízké podobnosti mezi tím, jak kvantová
a klasická informace fungují na matematické úrovni.
Obvykle se tolik nezaměřujeme
na klasickou informaci ani nezačínáme každou lekci série s klasickou informací takhle.
Následující lekce se budou mnohem výlučněji zaměřovat na kvantovou informaci a výpočty.
Ale zde na začátku
je to rozumný přístup a vrací se k myšlence, že uvažování o klasické informaci
může sloužit jako cenný zdroj vodítka pro pochopení kvantové informace.
Budeme také diskutovat
důležitý koncept tenzorového součinu v
této části lekce.
Tenzorové součiny jsou kriticky důležité v kvantové informaci, ale vyskytují se i
v klasickém kontextu.
Pak přejdeme ke kvantové informaci a podobně jako v předchozí lekci budeme diskutovat kvantové stavy,
standardní bázová měření,
a unitární operace tentokrát
pro více systémů.
Začneme tím, že budeme mluvit
o klasických stavech více systémů.
Vzpomeň si z předchozí
lekce, že klasický stav systému je
konfigurace tohoto systému, kterou lze rozpoznat a
popsat jednoznačně
bez jakékoli nejistoty nebo chyby. A v matematických termínech, když odkazujeme na množinu klasických stavů,
myslíme tím jednoduše konečnou a neprázdnou množinu.
Začneme naši diskuzi
o více systémech předpokladem, že máme
právě dva systémy X a Y.
X má nějakou množinu klasických stavů, kterou budeme nazývat sigma stejně
jako v předchozí lekci, a Y má nějakou množinu klasických stavů,
kterou budeme nazývat gamma. Množiny sigma a gamma
mohou být stejné nebo mohou být různé,
ale dáváme jim různá jména nejen proto, že
mohou být různými množinami, ale také proto, že nám pomůže
udržet věci jasné, pokud jim dáme různá jména.
Zjistíme, že je poměrně
snadné zobecnit celou tuto diskuzi od dvou systémů na libovolný počet systémů, ale
začínáme se dvěma systémy,
abychom se mohli soustředit na základní myšlenky bez uvíznutí v detailech.
WEBVTT
Nyní si představ, že
dáme X a Y vedle sebe, X vlevo a Y vpravo, a pohlížíme na tyto dva systémy společně
jako by tvořily jeden složený systém.
Abychom tomuto novému systému dali název, můžeme ho zapsat jako
uspořádanou dvojici takto, nebo můžeme jednoduše
juxtaponovat obě písmena takto.
Obě formy jsou běžné a
můžeme si vybrat kteroukoli nebo kteroukoli je vhodnější.
V každém případě ho budeme číst jako XY.
Velmi přirozená otázka
v tuto chvíli je: jaké jsou klasické stavy tohoto nového složeného systému XY?
A odpověď na tuto otázku je, že množina klasických stavů XY je kartézský součin
dvou množin klasických stavů,
sigma a gamma, který
vidíš definovaný právě zde.
V daném okamžiku má X nějaký klasický stav,
který je prvkem sigma, a Y má nějaký klasický stav,
který je prvkem gamma,
a jednoduše o těchto dvou stavech uvažujeme společně jako by tvořily jeden stav, a to je přesně pojem,
který kartézský součin zachycuje. Máme dva prvky,
jeden z každé naší množiny, a chceme o
těchto dvou prvcích uvažovat společně
jako by tvořily jeden
prvek z jedné množiny.
Je třeba říci, že zde existuje předpoklad, a to, že víme,
který z našich systémů je X a který je Y,
a není mezi nimi žádná záměna. Není důležité, aby X byl fyzicky na levé straně
a Y na pravé,
ale spíše to, že oba
systémy jsou rozlišitelné a my jsme se rozhodli
je takto uspořádat jen abychom měli jasno, který je který.
Zde je velmi jednoduchý příklad, kde sigma je binární abeceda a gamma je množina
obsahující čtyři barvy karet.
Pokud X uchovává binární hodnotu a Y uchovává jednu ze čtyř barev karet, pak existuje osm
možných klasických stavů
dvojice XY, které
vidíš vypsané právě zde.
Pro více než dva systémy se to zobecňuje přímočarým způsobem.
Konkrétně, pokud X1 až Xn jsou systémy s klasickými
stavovými množinami sigma jedna až sigma n.
Pak pokud si představíme, že seskupíme
n systémů dohromady a pohlížíme na ně jako na jeden systém, množina klasických stavů je
dána kartézským součinem
n množin klasických stavů
sigma jedna až sigma n.
Jak vidíš právě zde na obrazovce. Kartézský součin
může být definován takto pro libovolný počet množin.
Například, pokud máme tři systémy a všechny sdílejí binární abecedu jako svou množinu klasických stavů, tedy jinými slovy máme tři bity,
pak existuje osm
možných klasických stavů tří bitů považovaných
za jeden systém a vidíš je vypsané právě zde.
Každý systém individuálně může
být ve stavu nula nebo jedna, a procházíme všemi
možnými kombinacemi.
N-tice klasických stavů může být alternativně zapsána jako řetězec, kde vypustíme
závorky a čárky, jak vidíš právě zde.
A to je zvlášť rozumné, když uvažujeme o
klasických stavech jako o symbolech, jako v velmi běžném příkladu
binární abecedy,
ke které se stále vracíme. Někdy je to velmi pohodlné a má tendenci
zjednodušit naše výrazy
a udělat je méně přeplněné. Pojem řetězce je ve skutečnosti formalizován
v matematických termínech pomocí kartézských součinů,
takže je to skutečně jen
alternativní zápis a ne něco konceptuálně odlišného.
Jako příklad řekněme, že máme
10 bitů X1 až X10.
To znamená, že množina klasických stavů 10 bitů dohromady,
o které bys přirozeně přemýšlel jako o 10-bitovém registru
v počítači například,
je desetinásobný kartézský
součin binární abecedy se sebou samou.
A pokud zapíšeme tyto stavy jako řetězce, vypadají jako vidíš právě
zde, je jich 1 024,
takže samozřejmě nejsou všechny vypsány zde. Tyto tři tečky zde
mají naznačit, že existuje vzor, který lze odvodit,
a doufejme, že myšlence rozumíš. Nyní existuje konvence,
kterou budeme dodržovat pro uspořádání prvků
množin kartézských součinů,
a je důležité to
upřesnit kvůli reprezentaci jak pravděpodobnostních stavů, tak kvantových stavů jako vektorů.
Konvence spočívá v tom, že
prvky množin kartézských součinů řadíme lexikograficky, což v podstatě znamená slovníkové uspořádání.
Konkrétněji, začínáme předpokladem, že každá z jednotlivých množin, jejichž kartézský součin bereme, již má své vlastní uspořádání,
a na danou n-tici nebo řetězec se díváme jako na slovo a řadíme je abecedně.
Jiný způsob, jak to říci, je, že pozice v
n-tici nebo řetězci klesají ve významnosti
zleva doprava,
stejně jako když píšeme čísla pomocí číslic nula až devět.
Zde je příklad, který má
toto objasnit.
Pokud vezmeme kartézský součin množin obsahujících
jedna, dva a tři a binární abecedu, dostaneme množinu obsahující šest prvků,
a zde jsou vypsány v
pořadí, které je popisováno.
Všechny prvky s
jedničkou na první pozici přicházejí před všemi prvky s dvojkou na první pozici a ty přicházejí před všemi prvky
WEBVTT
s trojkou na první pozici. A kdykoli dva prvky
souhlasí na první pozici, spoléháme na uspořádání
na druhé pozici.
To je tedy uspořádání, které
používáme pro kartézské součiny.
Všimni si, že když použijeme tuto konvenci a zapíšeme n-tice jako řetězce, pozorujeme některé velmi známé vzory.
Například, kartézský součin
binární abecedy se sebou samou je uspořádán tak, jak vidíš právě zde,
a můžeš o těchto řetězcích přemýšlet jako o číselně uspořádaných, pokud vezmeš tyto řetězce
jako binární kódování nezáporných čísel a to se zobecňuje
na libovolnou délku řetězce. Přejdeme-li k pravděpodobnostním stavům, již víme z předchozí lekce,
že pravděpodobnostní stav přiřazuje pravděpodobnost každému klasickému
stavu daného systému.
Pokud máme složený systém, kde jsme vzali dva nebo více systémů a kolektivně je považujeme za
jeden systém, jak jsme právě diskutovali,
pak pravděpodobnostní stav
tohoto složeného systému musí přiřazovat pravděpodobnosti prvkům kartézského součinu
jednotlivých systémů,
množin klasických stavů. To proto, že tato je
množina klasických stavů složeného systému.
Například, předpokládejme,
že X a Y jsou bity, máme tento příklad
pravděpodobnostního stavu XY.
Pravděpodobnost, že oba
bity jsou nula, je jedna polovina, a pravděpodobnost, že oba
bity jsou jedna, je jedna polovina, takže tyto dva bity se nikdy neshodují.
Je to platný pravděpodobnostní stav XY a můžeme ho alternativně
zapsat jako vektor
jak vidíš právě zde a zde vidíš, že
dodržujeme konvenci, kterou jsem před chvílí popsal pro uspořádání těchto klasických stavů.
Toto je příklad
pravděpodobnostního stavu, kde jsou X a Y korelovány, a to je smysl, ve kterém je celek
větší než součet jeho částí. Jak jsem naznačil dříve, nejde jednoduše o to, že máme pravděpodobnostní stav
X a pravděpodobnostní stav Y a dáme je dohromady, ale spíše nejprve dáme
systémy dohromady
a pak uvažujeme o
pravděpodobnostních stavech složeného systému.
Abychom byli přesnější ohledně
korelací mezi systémy, začneme definováním pojmu nezávislosti, který je v podstatě
absencí korelace.
Přitom termín nezávislost odkazuje
na statistickou nezávislost na rozdíl od lineární nezávislosti
vektorů například.
Je to základní pojem v
pravděpodobnosti a statistice.
Pokud máme dva systémy X a Y a máme na mysli nějaký pravděpodobnostní
stav XY, pak říkáme, že X a Y jsou nezávislé,
pokud je vzorec, který
vidíš právě zde, pravdivý pro každý výběr klasických
stavů a a b systémů X a Y.
Jeden způsob, jak interpretovat tuto
podmínku nezávislosti, je, že říká, že pravděpodobnost, že X je v libovolném klasickém stavu
a pravděpodobnost, že Y je v jiném klasickém stavu, nemají absolutně
nic společného.
Takže zjistit, v jakém stavu
je jeden ze systémů, neovlivní
pravděpodobnosti spojené se stavy druhého systému.
Pokud si představíš náhodný výběr
nějakého klasického stavu X podle určitého postupu a pak náhodný výběr
nějakého klasického stavu Y
podle jiného postupu, který není žádným způsobem
spojen s tím pro X, jako kdyby jedna osoba hodila mincí
a jiná osoba v
jiné místnosti hodila kostkou, pak je toto vzorec,
který bys použil pro výpočet pravděpodobností
různých kombinací
stavů. Podstata definice je, že nezávislost je
situace, kdy je vzorec platný.
Když přemýšlíme o pravděpodobnostních stavech v termínech vektorů pravděpodobnosti, existuje jednoduché vyjádření
této podmínky,
konkrétně pokud máme
pravděpodobnostní stav XY, který můžeme vyjádřit jako
vektor v Diracově notaci
jak vidíš právě zde. Pak říci, že X a Y jsou nezávislé, je ekvivalentní existenci
dvou vektorů pravděpodobnosti,
ket Phi a ket Psi, které mimochodem můžeme
jednoduše číst jako Phi a Psi pro stručnost, reprezentujících
pravděpodobnostní stavy X a Y zvlášť, které splňují tuto rovnost,
kterou vidíš právě zde.
Pro všechny volby a a b je to v podstatě
přeformulování definice v termínech vektorů.
Například, zde je pravděpodobnostní
stav páru bitů XY, pro který jsou X a Y nezávislé.
Podmínka, která je
nutná pro nezávislost, je pravdivá pro vektory,
které vidíš právě zde.
To znamená, že pravděpodobnost
pro každé možné nastavení dvou bitů je dána součinem odpovídajících pravděpodobností
pro jednotlivé bity.
Například, pravděpodobnost, že oba
bity mají hodnotu nula, je rovna jedné šestině, což se rovná jedné
čtvrtině krát dvě třetiny,
a podobně pro
ostatní tři možnosti, které lze zkontrolovat jednu po druhé.
Pro pravděpodobnostní stav, který jsme viděli dříve, na druhé straně, kde máme
dva bity, které vždy souhlasí a nabývají hodnot nula a
jedna s pravděpodobností jedna polovina,
nemáme nezávislost a proto říkáme, že
bity jsou korelovány.
Korelace jednoduše znamená
absenci nezávislosti.
Jednoduchý způsob, jak dokázat, že
tyto dva bity nejsou nezávislé, je předpokládat, že jsou, a odvodit spor.
Konkrétně, pokud by dva
bity byly nezávislé, musela by existovat
čísla q0, q1, r0 a r1,
WEBVTT
reprezentující pravděpodobnosti
pro oba jednotlivé bity, takže tyto rovnice
pravě zde jsou splněny.
Toto jsou pravděpodobnosti,
které pocházejí z našeho vektoru, a toto jsou
rovnice, které musí být pravdivé dle podmínky nezávislosti.
Ale pokud se podíváme na tuto
druhou rovnici zde, vidíme, že vyžaduje, aby
q0 krát r1 bylo rovno nule,
ale jediný způsob, jak může
součin dvou reálných čísel být roven nule, je, že alespoň jedno z těchto
čísel je samo rovno nule.
Toto se někdy nazývá
vlastností nulového součinu reálných čísel.
Jiný způsob, jak to říci, je, že součin dvou nenulových reálných
čísel je vždy nenulový.
Takže tato rovnice
zde implikuje, že buď q0 je rovno nule nebo r1 je rovno nule,
ale z první a poslední rovnice vidíme, že ani
jedna z těchto dvou alternativ nemůže být pravdivá.
Pokud je q0 rovno nule, pak tento součin musí být roven nule, ale není roven nule,
a pokud je r1 rovno nule,
pak tento součin musí být roven nule, ale to také není pravda.
Máme tedy spor
a dospíváme k závěru, že X a Y nejsou nezávislé, tedy jsou korelovány.
Pojem nezávislosti,
který jsme právě diskutovali, a konkrétně jeho vyjádření v termínech vektorů
pravděpodobnosti, úzce souvisí
s operací, která může
být prováděna na vektorech, známou jako tenzorový součin.
Tenzorové součiny mohou být
definovány nejen pro vektory, ale i pro matice,
a ve skutečnosti lze pojem tenzorového součinu definovat
i pro mnoho jiných druhů
matematických objektů.
Lze je popsat
docela abstraktním způsobem, který je důležitý a
užitečný v čisté matematice, ale tenzorové součiny pro vektory
můžeme také definovat velmi jednoduchým a konkrétním způsobem, a to je cesta,
kterou v této lekci vezmeme.
Pokud máme dva sloupcové vektory Phi a Psi zapsané ve formách, které vidíš zde, kde sigma a gamma jsou libovolné
volby množin klasických stavů,
které preferujeme, nebo indexy, pokud dáváš přednost, pak tenzorový součin těchto vektorů je vektor, který vidíš právě zde.
Procházíme všemi prvky
kartézského součinu dvou množin, sigma a gamma, a složka tohoto
vektoru, která odpovídá
každé dvojici ab, která je
zde zapsána jako řetězec, se rovná součinu
odpovídajících složek
těchto dvou vektorů. Jinými slovy, složka ab tenzoru Phi ⊗ Psi je součinem složky a
vektoru Phi a složky b vektoru Psi,
a to je smysl
toho, co je zde zapsáno.
V podstatě, toto je stejná operace, kterou jsme viděli před chvílí, když jsme diskutovali nezávislost,
a nyní jí jen dáváme jméno.
Zde je přesně ten stejný příklad,
který jsme viděli před chvílí, zapsaný explicitněji v
termínech tenzorového součinu.
Opět, jedna šestina se rovná jedné čtvrtině krát jedna třetina, jedna dvanáctina se rovná jedné čtvrtině
krát jedna třetina a tak dále.
Zde jsou mimochodem
několika alternativní způsoby zápisu tenzorového
součinu dvou vektorů.
Když používáme Diracovu notaci a zapíšeme dva kety
vedle sebe takto, znamená to tenzorový součin.
Takže na tenzorový součin můžeš nahlížet jako na výchozí způsob násobení dvou sloupcových vektorů.
Nedávalo by žádný smysl
přemýšlet o součinu sloupcových vektorů takto v termínech maticového násobení, protože dimenze nesedí,
takže zde opravdu není obava
ohledně nejednoznačnosti.
Tenzorový součin lze také zapsat
takto uvnitř ketu, a to znamená
přesně to samé.
Je to tenzorový součin
dvou vektorů.
První způsob je velmi běžný a ve skutečnosti je možná běžnější zapsat tenzorový součin takto bez symbolu tenzorového součinu,
než se symbolem. Druhý způsob je
rozhodně mnohem méně běžný, ale někdy je docela užitečný, zejména
jako způsob, jak eliminovat potřebu
dalších závorek v určitých situacích.
Tenzorové součiny lze také vyjádřit
explicitně v termínech skutečných sloupců
čísel, jak vidíš právě zde,
pokud vezmeme tenzorový součin těchto dvou sloupcových vektorů právě zde, pak je to vektor, který dostaneme,
a vidíš, že složky jsou součiny složek
pocházejících z těchto dvou vektorů.
Pořadí složek
tenzorového součinu je konzistentní s
definicí z před chvíle za předpokladu, že dodržujeme konvenci,
kterou jsem popsal dříve pro uspořádání prvků
množin kartézských součinů.
Dodržovat tuto konvenci je ekvivalentní uvažování o tom, že indexy prvního vektoru mají
vyšší významnost než indexy druhého vektoru,
takže vidíš, že jak procházíme složkami tenzorového součinu, máme všechny součiny zahrnující první složku
prvního vektoru vlevo,
což je alfa jedna. Pak všechny součiny
zahrnující druhou složku vektoru vlevo,
což je alfa dva a tak dále.
Zde je příklad, kde
vektor vlevo má tři složky a vektor
vpravo má čtyři složky, takže vidíme jasněji, co se děje.
WEBVTT
Máme tři složky v prvním vektoru, takže začneme zápisem tří kopií druhého vektoru a pak každou z těchto kopií
vynásobíme odpovídající složkou
prvního vektoru takto.
Přeneseme alfy dovnitř takto, a zde jednoduše
násobíme vektory skaláry,
a nakonec odstraníme
závorky z kopií a tvoříme jeden sloupcový
vektor, jak vidíš právě zde.
Jako důležitá poznámka si všimni, že máme následující vzorce pro tenzorový součin
standardních bázových vektorů.
Pokud vezmeme tenzorový
součin ketu a a ketu b, který můžeme zapsat se
symbolem tenzorového součinu nebo bez, jak vidíš zde,
pak výsledkem je jednoduše ket ab.
Pokud chceme zapsat ab jako uspořádanou dvojici, nikoli jako řetězec, můžeme to udělat a dostaneme
tento výraz právě zde,
ale je mnohem běžnější
zapsat toto právě zde, kde vynecháme závorku,
ale necháme čárku.
V jistém smyslu je
tato forma se závorkou možná správnější, ale je to docela standardní
konvence v matematice,
že závorky se odstraňují, když nejsou nutné nebo užitečné.
Můžeš o nich přemýšlet jako o implicitních v tomto zápisu a je to méně přeplněné
a příjemnější pohled.
Tenzorový součin má
důležitou vlastnost, která spočívá v tom, že je bilineární, a to znamená, že je lineární
v každém ze dvou argumentů za předpokladu, že druhý je fixní.
Podrobněji, je
lineární v prvním argumentu, což je vyjádřeno těmito dvěma rovnicemi, které vidíš právě zde,
první říká, že
pokud sečteme dva vektory, Phi1 a Phi2, a pak vezmeme
tenzorový součin s Psi, dostaneme stejný výsledek, jako kdybychom vzali tenzorový součin
s Psi nejdříve a pak sčítali.
Druhá říká, že pokud
vynásobíme nějaký vektor Phi nějakým skalárem alfa a pak vezmeme
tenzorový součin s Psi,
výsledek je stejný, jako kdybychom nejdříve vzali tenzorový součin Phi a Psi a pak výsledek vynásobili alfa.
A máme také linearitu
v druhém argumentu, která je stejná, jen se role dvou argumentů zaměnily.
Tato bilinearita
je docela přímočará k ověření z definice, ale je dobré ji zapsat takto, protože tyto vzorce budeme často
používat.
Všimni si mimochodem, že skaláry volně procházejí tenzorové součiny ve smyslu, který je vyjádřen těmito
rovnostmi, které vidíš právě zde.
To znamená, že není žádný rozdíl
mezi vynásobením prvního argumentu skalárem alfa, v tomto případě vynásobením druhého
argumentu tímto skalárem,
nebo vynásobením celé
věci tímto skalárem.
Tyto rovnosti vyplývají z
těchto dvou rovnic právě zde a protože není
žádný rozdíl mezi těmito vektory, můžeme jednoduše zapsat
výraz jak vidíš právě zde
bez závorek, protože
není potřeba je.
Nepřidávají žádnou jasnost
ani neodstraňují žádnou nejednoznačnost, takže je jednoduše odstraníme a
dostaneme čistší výraz.
Vše toto se zobecňuje
na tři nebo více systémů.
Tenzorový součin
tří nebo více vektorů lze definovat zobecněním vzorce
pro tenzorový součin dvou vektorů přirozeným způsobem,
jak vidíš vyjádřeno právě zde. Každá složka tenzorového součinu je dána součinem
odpovídajících složek
vektorů, jejichž tenzorový součin
bereme.
Ekvivalentní způsob, jak
definovat tenzorový součin tří nebo více vektorů,
je udělat to rekurzivně, s konečným návratem k definici
tenzorového součinu dvou vektorů. Pokud je tedy n alespoň tři, můžeme o
tenzorové součinu n vektorů přemýšlet
Phi1 až Phi n jako o tenzorové součinu mezi vektorem, který dostaneme
tenzorové součinem prvních n minus jedna z
nich, s posledním vektorem,
a pokud chceš vědět,
co je tenzorový součin prvních n minus jedna vektorů, buď aplikuješ vzorec
znovu v případě, že n minus jedna
je alespoň tři, nebo použiješ definici
z předtím, pokud je n minus jedna rovno dvěma.
Tyto dva způsoby přemýšlení
o tenzorových součinech tří nebo více vektorů jsou ekvivalentní.
Tentokrát, když máme
tři nebo více vektorů, jejichž tenzorový součin bereme, nepoužíváme termín bilineární,
ale místo toho používáme termín multilineární,
ale myšlenka je stejná.
Tenzorový součin je lineární
v každé z pozic za předpokladu, že vektory v
všech ostatních pozicích
jsou fixní. Přejdeme-li k měřením
více systémů v pravděpodobnostních stavech,
ihned dostaneme specifikaci toho, jak měření
fungují pro více systémů, jednoduše tím, že o nich
kolektivně uvažujeme jako o jednotlivých systémech
za předpokladu, že jsou měřeny
všechny systémy.
Jako jednoduchý příklad předpokládejme, že máme dva
bity X a Y a kolektivně jsou v tomto pravděpodobnostním
stavu právě zde,
který jsme viděli dříve. Přirozeně, pokud změříme
oba tyto bity, dostaneme výsledek 00,
tedy nulu pro první měření a nulu pro druhé měření, s pravděpodobností jedna polovina, a dostaneme výsledek 1,1
WEBVTT
také s pravděpodobností jedna polovina. To je docela přímočaré.
V podstatě, měření všech systémů je ekvivalentní měření
celého složeného systému.
Pokud však neměříme všechny
systémy, ale místo toho změříme
jen některé ze systémů, pak situace není
zcela okamžitě jasná.
Omezíme se opět na případ právě dvou
systémů, abychom viděli podstatu toho, co se děje, v co nejjednodušším možném prostředí.
Můžeme položit následující otázku: předpokládejme, že máme dva systémy X a Y, které jsou společně jako pár
v nějakém konkrétním pravděpodobnostním stavu.
Co se stane, pokud změříme
jen X a neuděláme nic s Y?
Na tuto otázku lze odpovědět pomocí základní teorie pravděpodobnosti.
Nejprve víme, že pravděpodobnost, že měření
dá konkrétní výsledek, musí být dána tímto vzorcem,
který vidíš právě zde.
Můžeme přemýšlet o pravděpodobnostech pro každý z klasických
stavů páru XY, jako kdybychom oba změřili, a sečteme všechny pravděpodobnosti,
které jsou konzistentní s tím, že X je v libovolném klasickém stavu
a, na který se zaměřujeme.
To je důvod, proč součet právě zde je jen přes klasické stavy b systému Y.
Jeden způsob, jak tento
vzorec interpretovat, je, že pravděpodobnost vidět konkrétní klasický
stav X, pokud ho změříme,
musí být konzistentní s pravděpodobností vidět tento stav, pokud
jsme také změřili Y, i když jsme to neudělali,
to je velmi přirozené a intuitivní. Pravděpodobnost, že měření X dá konkrétní výsledek, nemůže záviset na tom, zda Y
bylo také změřeno,
bez ohledu na výsledek.
Takže to nám říká, jaké jsou
pravděpodobnosti pro různé možné
výsledky měření, ale co se stane s Y nebo naší
znalostí Y jako výsledek?
Odpověď je, že může stále
existovat nějaká nejistota ohledně stavu Y jako
výsledek změření X
a vidění konkrétního výsledku. A tato nejistota je reprezentována tímto vzorcem právě zde pro podmíněnou pravděpodobnost,
že Y je v nějakém konkrétním
klasickém stavu b, za předpokladu, že X je v nějakém klasickém stavu,
libovolném klasickém stavu a,
který jsme náhodou změřili.
Přesněji, pravděpodobnost, že Y je
v nějakém klasickém stavu b, za předpokladu, že X je v klasickém stavu a,
se rovná pravděpodobnosti,
že X je v a a Y je v b, děleno pravděpodobností, že X
je v klasickém stavu a.
Takže pokud změříme X, uvidíme
různé klasické stavy s pravděpodobnostmi danými
tímto vzorcem právě zde,
a v závislosti na tom, jaký výsledek dostaneme, můžeme mít stále nějakou nejistotu ohledně klasického stavu Y, a
tato nejistota se odráží
tímto vzorcem právě zde.
Existuje ve skutečnosti velmi snadný
způsob, jak to vše přeformulovat a provádět výpočty
pro konkrétní případy pomocí Diracovy notace,
a jde to takto.
Začneme zápisem
pravděpodobnostního stavu XY jako vektoru takto, a
toto je zcela obecné.
Složky jsou označeny Pab a tato čísla mohou být libovolná, pokud celý vektor
je vektorem pravděpodobnosti.
Můžeme vyjádřit ket ab jako
tenzorový součin, jak vidíš právě zde, a pak můžeme použít
bilinearitu tenzorového součinu
a konkrétně skutečnost, že je lineární v druhém argumentu, k vyjádření tohoto vektoru,
jak vidíš právě zde.
Efektivně izolujeme standardní bázové vektory
na levé straně a dáváme na pravou stranu vše, co potřebujeme,
aby to umožnilo, protože to odhalí, co se stane, když
změříme první systém X.
Konkrétně, pravděpodobnost
dostat konkrétní výsledek a je součtem všech pravděpodobností, které se objevují
v závorce vedle ketu a.
A podmíněně na získání
konkrétního výsledku a, vektor pravděpodobnosti, který popisuje veškerou zbývající nejistotu ohledně Y,
je vektor, který byl
v závorce vedle a.
Jenže ho musíme normalizovat, aby byl vektorem pravděpodobnosti, a to znamená, že
musíme tento vektor vydělit
součtem složek tohoto vektoru, aby tvořil vektor pravděpodobnosti.
Přitom je součet brán přes všechna
c v gamma, nikoli b, jen proto, abychom použili jiný název proměnné, aby nedošlo k záměně
ohledně rozsahu
proměnných, abychom tak řekli.
Součty v čitateli
a jmenovateli by měly být považovány za oddělené věci a můžeme se vyhnout jakékoli šanci
záměny tím,
že použijeme různé
proměnné pro oba součty.
Zde je rychlý příklad k
ilustraci toho, jak to vše funguje.
Předpokládejme, že XY je pár bitů v tomto pravděpodobnostním stavu právě zde. Abychom pochopili, co se stane,
když změříme první bit
a neuděláme nic s druhým, zapíšeme vektor, jak vidíš právě zde, kde ket nula a ket
jedna na první pozici
jsou izolovány, jak jsme
popsali před chvílí.
První možnost je,
že výsledek měření je nula, a pravděpodobnost,
že se to stane, je součtem pravděpodobností
uvnitř závorek,
WEBVTT
které jsou v tenzoru s ketem nula. Takže dostaneme jedna dvanáctina plus jedna čtvrtina, což je jedna třetina, a
podmíněně na výsledku nula.
Pravděpodobnostní stav Y
se stane tímto normalizovaným vektorem, neboli vydělí se pravděpodobností,
kterou jsme právě vypočítali, a tak dostaneme
tento vektor právě zde.
Druhá možnost je, že výsledek měření je jedna, a výpočet se
provádí podobným způsobem pomocí druhého členu ve výrazu
místo prvního členu. A pokud chceš ověřit detaily, klidně si jako vždy pozastav video, abys měl chvíli na to.
Můžeš provádět stejné
druhy výpočtů, abys zjistil, co se stane, když
je měřen Y, nikoli X.
Je to stejná metoda, jen díky symetrii mezi oběma systémy.
Tentokrát zapíšeme
vektor pravděpodobnosti takto, izolujeme standardní bázové vektory vpravo, jak vidíš právě zde,
ale jinak to funguje
přesně stejným způsobem.
Tuto metodu lze také použít
pro více než dva systémy.
Může být trochu
nepřehledné pouze zapsat všechny požadované výrazy, ale konceptuálně je to
přesně stejná myšlenka.
Nakonec, pro část lekce
o klasické informaci se podíváme na operace
s pravděpodobnostními stavy
více systémů. Následujeme stejné úvahy, které jsme již viděli několikrát.
Dospíváme k závěru, že pravděpodobnostní operace na více systémech jsou stejné
jako pravděpodobnostní operace na jednotlivých systémech, reprezentované
stochastickými maticemi.
Ale tentokrát tyto matice
mají řádky a sloupce, které odpovídají kartézskému součinu množin klasických stavů jednotlivých systémů.
To znamená, jednoduše
pohlížíme na složený systém jako by byl jedním systémem a vracíme se k popisu toho, jak pravděpodobnostní operace fungují
pro jednotlivé systémy z
předchozí lekce.
Zde je příklad operace nazývané controlled-NOT
operace na dvou bitech X a Y.
Toto je ve skutečnosti deterministická operace a způsob, jakým funguje, je,
že pokud se X rovná jedné, pak se na Y provede operace NOT
a jinak, pokud se X rovná
nule, pak se nic nestane.
Bit X se někdy
nazývá řídicí bit, protože určuje, zda
se na Y použije operace NOT nebo ne,
a Y se nazývá cílový bit, protože je to bit, na který se operace NOT aplikuje.
Také si lze představit
zaměnit role X a Y, takže Y se stane řídicím
bitem a X se stane cílem, ale to je jiná operace
od té, která je zde popsána, protože operace není
symetrická mezi X a Y.
Obojí se nazývají
controlled-NOT operace a stačí nám specifikovat,
který bit je řídicím a
který je cílovým.
Tato operace má účinek,
který vidíš právě zde na standardních bázových stavech, a můžeš zkontrolovat tento
účinek oproti definici
operace. A zde je maticová
reprezentace operace.
Když uvažujeme o této operaci, máme na mysli, že existují
tyto dva oddělené bity a hrají role, které jsem právě popsal, přičemž
X je řídicí bit
a Y je cílový bit, ale o tomto účinku
nebo této maticové reprezentaci opravdu není nic,
co by nás nutilo
přemýšlet o těchto dvou bitech jako o oddělených bitech.
Alternativně bychom jednoduše mohli
přemýšlet o této operaci jako o deterministické
operaci na systému se čtyřmi klasickými stavy,
které jsme se rozhodli pojmenovat
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 a 1,1.
Zde je další příklad
pravděpodobnostní operace na dvou bitech, která tentokrát není deterministická
operace.
Operace nastaví Y na hodnotu X s pravděpodobností jedna polovina, jinak to jde opačně a nastaví X na hodnotu Y.
Tato operace nemá zvláštní název, je to jen příklad.
A zde je maticová
reprezentace této operace.
Vidíš, že ji lze vyjádřit jako průměr dvou matic, jedna reprezentuje deterministickou operaci,
kde Y je nastaveno na libovolnou
hodnotu uloženou v X, a druhá, která nastaví
X na hodnotu Y.
Zde tedy vidíme, že můžeme brát průměry stochastických matic a dostávat nové, stejně jako jsme měli v předchozí lekci.
Nyní zvažme
následující otázku. Předpokládejme, že máme dvě
pravděpodobnostní operace, každá na vlastním systému,
popsány jak obvykle stochastickými
maticemi, a přesněji řekněme, že M je
pravděpodobnostní operace
na systému X a N je
pravděpodobnostní operace na systému Y.
Otázka je, pokud
současně provedeme M na X a N na Y, jak popíšeme
účinek, který to má
na složený systém XY?
Přemýšlíme-li o tom
intuitivně na chvíli, pokud současně
provádíme obě operace na jejich vlastních systémech,
pak ve skutečnosti
provádíme operaci na složeném systému, takže by měla být popsána
nějakou stochastickou maticí.
Stručná odpověď na tuto
otázku je, že matice se získá tenzorové součinem, nikoli mezi vektory, jak
jsme diskutovali dříve,
WEBVTT
ale mezi maticemi, v tomto
případě maticemi M a N.
Věnujme tedy chvíli
diskuzi o tenzorových součinech matic a pak se
vrátíme k této otázce.
Zde je definice
tenzorového součinu matic a
je velmi analogická tenzorové součinu vektorů.
Předpokládejme, že dvě
matice, se kterými pracujeme, jsou zapsány ve formách, které vidíš zde, takže složky M jsou
označeny alfa ab, kde a a b
procházejí nějakou množinou klasických stavů sigma a složky N jsou
označeny beta cd, kde c a d
procházejí nějakou množinou klasických stavů gamma.
Pak součin M a N je matice, kterou vidíš právě zde.
Co máme, je podobné
tenzorové součinu vektorů.
Řádky a sloupce M ⊗ N odpovídají dvojicím klasických stavů, které jsou zde zapsány jako řetězce,
a složky jsou součiny odpovídajících složek M a N.
Zde je další způsob zápisu v termínech jednotlivých
složek těchto matic.
Složka ac bd matice M ⊗ N je součinem složky ab
matice M a složky cd matice N.
Existuje jiný způsob, jak
popsat M ⊗ N, a to, že je to
jedinečná matice, která transformuje libovolný vektor tvaru Phi ⊗ Psi
na tenzorový součin M aplikovaného na Phi a N aplikovaného na Psi, a to musí být pravda pro každou volbu
těchto vektorů Phi a Psi.
Jeden způsob, jak o tom přemýšlet,
je, že tenzorový součin matic perfektně harmonuje s tenzorové součinem vektorů.
Toto je rovnice, o níž bys přirozeně doufal, že bude pravdivá, a skutečně je.
V termínech explicitně zapsaných matic lze tenzorový součin
definovat, jak vidíš zde.
V této rovnici je mnoho teček a mají ilustrovat vzor, který je stejný vzor,
jaký jsme měli pro vektory, jenže nyní máme řádky a sloupce
na rozdíl od pouhých sloupcových vektorů.
Pokud to není jasné, může pomoci
následující příklad.
Zde mluvíme o
tenzorové součinu dvou matic 2×2.
Nejprve zapíšeme čtyři
kopie druhé matice, jednu pro každou složku první matice.
Každou z těchto
kopií druhé matice vynásobíme odpovídající
složkou první matice,
a pak to vše shromáždíme do
jedné matice 4×4, jak vidíš právě zde.
Tenzorový součin tří nebo více matic lze také definovat analogickým způsobem a možná nejjednodušší
způsob, jak to vyjádřit,
je jak vidíš právě zde,
kde máme vzorec pro každou složku tenzorového součinu, který je jednoduše součinem
odpovídajících složek.
Tenzorový součin tří nebo více matic lze také definovat rekurzivně v termínech tenzorového
součinu právě dvou matic, stejně jako jsme měli pro vektory.
A poslední poznámka je,
že tenzorový součin matic je multiplikativní, což znamená, že součin tenzorových součinů
se rovná tenzorové součinu
součinů.
O tom lze přemýšlet
jako o zobecnění vzorce z před chvíle pro účinek tenzorového
součinu matic
na tenzorový součin vektorů. A opět, toto je něco, o čem bychom jistě doufali, že bude pravdivé, a můžeme být rádi, že je,
a tuto skutečnost budeme využívat,
kdykoli budeme potřebovat.
A nyní se můžeme vrátit
k otázce z dřívějška, která se ptá, jak popíšeme
účinek provedení operace M na systému X
a operace N na systému Y dohromady jako operace
na složeném systému XY.
A odpověď na tuto
otázku je, že účinek je popsán
tenzorové součinem M a N.
Tenzorové součiny reprezentují nezávislost, tentokrát mezi operacemi, na rozdíl od toho, co jsme viděli
dříve pro vektory pravděpodobnosti.
Zde je rychlý příklad. Předpokládejme, že provedeme
pravděpodobnostní operaci popsanou touto maticí na bitu X.
Tato operace se
v lekci jedna vyskytla a současně provedeme
operaci NOT na bitu Y.
Kombinovaná operace na páru XY je tedy reprezentována tenzorové součinem matic odpovídajících těmto dvěma operacím.
Zde je ta pro X a
zde je operace NOT pro Y, a dostaneme tuto matici,
kterou vidíš právě zde.
A vidíš, že skutečně
je to stochastická matice, a to bude vždy platit.
Tenzorový součin libovolných
dvou stochastických matic nebo libovolného počtu stochastických
matic bude vždy stochastický.
Je to velmi běžná situace,
kdy se setkáme s situací, ve které se provede jedna operace na jednom systému a na druhém systému se nic nedělá.
V této situaci dodržujeme přesně stejný předpis s tím, že nedělání ničeho je reprezentováno maticí identity.
Například, pokud máme dva bity X a
Y a resetujeme bit X do stavu nula, což je totéž,
jako provést konstantní
nulovou funkci na X, a neuděláme nic s Y, pak výsledná operace na páru XY
WEBVTT
je reprezentována tímto
tenzorové součinem právě zde.
Vše toto se zobecňuje
na libovolný počet systémů a uvidíme některé další příklady, když se obrátíme ke kvantovému kontextu, který funguje přesně stejným způsobem,
jenže máme unitární matice místo stochastických matic, a to je dost o
klasické informaci pro tuto chvíli.
Nyní obrátíme pozornost
ke kvantové informaci a tomu, jak funguje pro více systémů.
Vzor je stejný jako
pro klasickou informaci.
Více kvantových systémů lze považovat za jediné složené systémy a aplikovat to, co víme
z předchozí lekce.
Opět budou hrát klíčovou roli tenzorové součiny a celkově dostaneme popis toho, jak kvantová informace
funguje pro více systémů.
Tento popis je velmi analogický
a matematicky podobný tomu, co jsme právě viděli pro
klasickou informaci.
Začneme kvantovými stavy.
Kvantové stavy více systémů jsou reprezentovány sloupcovými vektory s komplexními číselnými složkami
a eukleidovskou normou rovnou jedné,
stejně jako kvantové stavy
jednotlivých systémů.
Tentokrát indexy
vektorů kvantových stavů odpovídají kartézskému součinu množin klasických stavů
jednotlivých systémů,
protože opět, to je
množina klasických stavů složeného systému.
Například, pokud X a Y jsou qubitů, pak množina klasických stavů páru XY dohromady je kartézský součin binární abecedy se sebou samou,
na který lze nahlížet jako na
množinu všech binárních řetězců délky dvě.
Takže tyto vektory, které vidíš zde, jsou všechny příklady vektorů kvantových stavů XY.
Pokud chceme, můžeme alternativně zapsat
tyto vektory takto, kde máme oddělený
ket pro každý qubit,
kde tenzorový součin
mezi nimi je implicitní.
Nebo lze také zapsat
symbol tenzorového součinu explicitně takto, pokud dáváš přednost.
A další možnost je
přidat ketu dolní index s názvy systémů,
které reprezentují, takto.
A to lze udělat se
symbolem tenzorového součinu nebo bez.
To může být někdy velmi užitečné pro udržení přehledu o věcech.
Toto jsou jen různé styly vyjádření stejných vektorů a můžeme si vybrat kteroukoli, nebo kterou preferujeme, nebo
která dává největší smysl
pro danou situaci. Když se věci stávají složitějšími, například, můžeme se rozhodnout, že jeden z
těchto stylů přidává jasnost
a jsme svobodní udělat
kteroukoli volbu chceme.
Tenzorové součiny vektorů kvantových stavů jsou také vektory kvantových stavů.
Pro případ dvou systémů například, pokud Phi je vektor kvantového stavu
systému X a Psi je vektor kvantového stavu
systému Y,
pak tenzorový součin Phi a Psi je vektor kvantového stavu XY.
Stavy takového druhu nazýváme produktovými stavy a podobně jako jsme viděli v klasickém pravděpodobnostním kontextu, reprezentují nezávislost
mezi systémy X a Y.
Takže například, pokud jedna osoba má laboratoř
v jedné části světa a vytvoří systém X a inicializuje ho do kvantového stavu Phi,
a jiná osoba v
jiné části světa nezávisle inicializuje systém Y do kvantového stavu Psi,
pak pokud se rozhodneme přemýšlet o XY jako o jednom systému, přestože jsou jeho dvě části v různých částech světa,
pak je složený systém XY
ve stavu Phi ⊗ Psi.
Toto vše se přirozeně zobecňuje na
více než dva systémy.
Pokud máme kvantové
stavy Psi1 až PsiN oddělených systémů X1 až Xn, pak tenzorový součin těchto n vektorů
reprezentuje kvantový stav, který se opět nazývá produktový stav složeného systému X1 až Xn.
Zde je příklad kvantového stavu dvou qubitů.
I když to tak možná ihned nevypadá, jde o příklad produktového stavu, protože ho lze zapsat
jako tenzorový součin, jak vidíš právě zde.
Takže je to příklad
produktového stavu bez ohledu na to, jak je zapsán; co je důležité, je to, zda
je možné ho zapsat jako tenzorový součin.
Tento kvantový stav, nicméně, který je opět stavem dvou
qubitů, není produktovým stavem.
Je duchově podobný
příkladu, který jsme viděli v pravděpodobnostním kontextu, dvou dokonale korelovaných náhodných bitů,
a stejný argument ukazuje, že ho nelze zapsat
jako tenzorový součin.
Přesuňme ho tedy sem a podívejme se na argument trochu podrobněji.
Představme si, že
bychom mohli zapsat tento stav jako tenzorový součin
dvou vektorů Phi a Psi.
Složka odpovídající
klasickému stavu 0,1 je pro tento vektor nula, což vidíme pouhým pohledem.
To by ale implikovalo, pokud by vektor byl tenzorové
součinem dvou vektorů, že nultá složka Phi
krát první složka Psi
by se rovnala nule, ale to znamená, že buď
nultá složka Phi nebo první složka Psi se rovná nule,
nebo obě by se mohly rovnat nule, ale to odporuje skutečnosti,
že tyto dva součiny zde musí být oba nenulové.
WEBVTT
Rovnají se jedné
odmocnině ze dvou. Argument je ve skutečnosti docela
totožný s tím, co jsme měli v pravděpodobnostním kontextu.
Na tom není nic výhradně
kvantového.
V každém případě zjistíme, že původní stav není produktovým stavem.
Všimni si, že není důležité,
aby tato dvě čísla byla jedna přes odmocninu ze dvou.
Co záleží, je jen to, že
obě hodnoty jsou nenulové.
Tento konkrétní kvantový stav
je velmi zajímavý. Je to příklad
provázaného stavu dvou qubitů.
O provázanosti budeme mluvit více
dále v sérii.
Provázanost může být složitá, zejména když mluvíme
o kvantových stavech v obecné formulaci
kvantové informace,
ale zde ve zjednodušeném popisu kvantové informace je provázanost ekvivalentní absenci nezávislosti.
Takže pro vektor kvantového stavu,
pokud není produktovým stavem, je to provázaný stav,
a tento konkrétní stav
je obecně považován za
archetypální příklad provázaného kvantového stavu.
A ve skutečnosti, někdy
o tomto stavu přemýšlíme jako o reprezentaci jedné jednotky provázanosti, zejména když přemýšlíme o provázanosti
jako o zdroji, který lze
použít k provádění zajímavých věcí.
Kvantový stav, o
kterém jsme právě mluvili, je jedním ze čtyř tzv. Bellových stavů, které vidíš zde
spolu s názvy,
které se pro tyto stavy běžně používají: Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus a Psi minus.
Všechny jsou provázané
a tvoří bázi pro prostor všech
vektorů reprezentujících stavy dvou qubitů.
Takže tyto čtyři vektory dohromady
se nazývají Bellova báze.
Je to velmi běžně
se vyskytující kolekce kvantových stavů pojmenovaná
na počest Johna Bella, který byl fyzik, jenž přinesl
velmi důležité příspěvky
ke studiu provázanosti v šedesátých letech.
Zde je pár dobře známých příkladů kvantových stavů tří qubitů.
První se nazývá GHZ stav.
Je trochu jako stav Phi
plus, který jsme právě viděli, ale pro tři qubity místo dvou.
A druhý příklad se nazývá W stav a vypadá tak, jak vidíš zde, takže je rovnoměrně rozložen přes
tři binární řetězce
délky tři, které mají
přesně jeden bit nastavený na jednu.
Ani jeden z těchto stavů není produktovým stavem a oba mají zajímavé vlastnosti a poměrně běžně se vyskytují jako příklady, takže je dobré o nich vědět,
a uvidíme je znovu.
Dále budeme mluvit o
měřeních systémů v kvantových stavech.
Sledujeme stejné úvahy,
které jsme v této lekci doposud sledovali, tedy přemýšlet o více systémech
jako o jednotlivých systémech. Ihned dospíváme k popisu toho, jak měření
více kvantových systémů fungují,
za předpokladu, že jsou měřeny
všechny systémy.
To znamená, pokud máme nějaký
vektor kvantového stavu Psi, který reprezentuje kvantový
stav n-tice systémů,
X1 až Xn, a změříme
celý složený systém, což je ekvivalentní měření
každého z jednotlivých systémů, pak každá možná n-tice
klasických stavů bude výsledkem měření
s pravděpodobností rovnou
absolutní hodnotě na druhou složky Psi, která
odpovídá dané n-tici.
Například, pokud máme
pár systémů XY v tomto kvantovém stavu právě zde, pak pokud změříme oba systémy,
dostaneme výsledek nula srdce, tedy nula pro měření X a srdce pro měření Y,
s pravděpodobností devět 25tin, a dostaneme výsledek jedna
piky s pravděpodobností 16/25.
To je opravdu docela přímočaré. V podstatě ignorujeme skutečnost, že se jedná o dva oddělené systémy, a pohlížíme na ně jako
na jeden systém,
ale to vyvolává
následující přirozenou otázku, kterou jsme již uvažovali
v klasickém kontextu.
Předpokládejme, že máme dva systémy X a Y, které jsou kolektivně
v nějakém kvantovém stavu, a neměříme oba, ale
změříme pouze jeden systém.
Řekněme, že změříme systém X a neuděláme nic s Y.
Samozřejmě se také můžeme ptát, co se stane, pokud změříme Y, nikoli
X, a obecněji, co se stane, pokud máme
tři nebo více systémů
a změříme jejich vlastní podmnožinu. Ale jakmile máme odpověď na tuto otázku, budeme mít odpovědi i
na tyto otázky.
Víme, že obecně
vektor kvantového stavu páru XY nabývá
formy, kterou vidíš právě zde, přičemž jak obvykle sigma a gamma
jsou množiny klasických stavů
X a Y.
Složky tohoto vektoru jsou
označeny alfa ab a procházejí všemi možnými volbami a a b,
a mohou být libovolná komplexní čísla, která způsobují, že tento vektor
je jednotkovým vektorem.
Nyní již víme, že pokud
jsou oba systémy změřeny, pak dostaneme pravděpodobnosti pro různé možné výsledky
WEBVTT
umocněním absolutní hodnoty odpovídající složky na druhou.
A takže pokud je změřen jen X, pak pravděpodobnost
dostat konkrétní výsledek a je dána tímto výrazem,
jednoduše sečteme přes všechny
možné výsledky b, které by mohly být obdrženy,
kdyby byl změřen i Y, přestože nebyl.
Myšlenka je stejná jako
v pravděpodobnostním kontextu.
Pravděpodobnost dostat
konkrétní výsledek při měření X nemůže
záviset na tom, zda byl také změřen Y.
Takže to nám říká, jaké jsou
pravděpodobnosti pro různé možné výsledky.
Navíc, dojde k nějaké
změně stavu Y jako výsledek provedení tohoto měření na X a obdržení konkrétního výsledku.
Podívejme se tedy na to, jak to funguje.
Podobně jako jsme to udělali v
pravděpodobnostním kontextu, můžeme vyjádřit
vektor kvantového stavu Psi, jak vidíš právě zde,
kde Phi a je tento vektor pro každou volbu klasického stavu a systému X,
používáme bilinearitu
tenzorového součinu stejně jako předtím.
Pouze nyní jsme se rozhodli pojmenovat
tyto různé vektory Phi a, jen pro pohodlnost.
Již jsme pozorovali, že pravděpodobnost, že měření dá
každý možný výsledek a, je jak vidíš právě zde,
ale nyní vidíme, že tato pravděpodobnost se rovná eukleidovské normě
na druhou vektoru Phi a,
a nyní, jako výsledek měření X dávajícího konkrétní výsledek a, máme, že kvantový stav
složeného systému XY
se stane tímto stavem,
který vidíš právě zde.
Stejně jako jsme měli pro jednotlivé systémy, stav se v podstatě zhroutí, ale ne zcela obecně,
zhroutí se jen do té míry, jak je potřeba, aby byl konzistentní
s tím, že měření X dalo výsledek a.
Kvantový stav Y se stane Phi a normalizovaným, tedy vydělíme jeho eukleidovskou normou,
aby se stal jednotkovým vektorem. Toto je analogické tomu, co se stalo v
pravděpodobnostním kontextu, kde namísto dělení
eukleidovskou normou,
jsme dělili součtem
složek Phi a, abychom dostali vektor pravděpodobnosti.
Ale zde, protože mluvíme
o kvantových stavech, dělíme eukleidovskou normou,
aby vznikl vektor kvantového stavu.
Podívejme se na pár příkladů, jak to funguje
pro konkrétní stav.
Zde je stav, který budeme uvažovat. Předpokládáme, že X a Y jsou qubity a jsou v tomto konkrétním stavu Psi.
A předpokládejme, že X je změřen.
Začneme zápisem stavu
Psi, jak vidíš právě zde, efektivně izolujeme
standardní bázové faktory X,
a tenzorujeme je s čímkoli potřebujeme, abychom dostali původní stav.
Stejně jako v obecném
popisu z před chvíle.
Pravděpodobnost dostat výsledek nula je eukleidovská norma na druhou
tohoto vektoru právě zde.
Věc, kterou tenzorujeme s ketem nula v našem vyjádření vektoru Psi.
A takže pravděpodobnost je tři čtvrtiny a podmíněně na
dostat výsledek nula.
Kvantový stav
páru XY se stane tímto, kde normalizujeme
vektor tenzorovaný s ketem nula,
a to je ekvivalentní
dělení odmocninou pravděpodobnosti, kterou
jsme právě vypočítali.
Pak zjednodušíme
a toto dostaneme.
Pravděpodobnost dostat
výsledek měření jedna se vypočítá podobným způsobem.
Vezmeme eukleidovskou normu na druhou
tohoto vektoru právě zde, věci, která je tenzorována s ketem
jedna v našem vyjádření Psi,
a výsledná
pravděpodobnost je jedna čtvrtina, což samozřejmě musí být, protože naše pravděpodobnosti
se musí sečíst na jednu.
V tomto případě se kvantový stav XY stane tímto, kde opět normalizujeme dělením eukleidovskou normou,
abychom dostali tento vektor kvantového stavu
jako výsledek.
Stejná metoda se používá
symetrickým způsobem, pokud je místo X měřen Y.
Zde je původní vektor kvantového stavu, a tentokrát, protože
je měřen Y místo X,
vyjádříme vektor Psi
jak vidíš právě zde, kde tentokrát izolujeme
standardní bázové vektory Y
místo X a tenzorujeme
s čímkoli potřebujeme, abychom dostali vyjádření Psi.
Procházíme výpočtem, který lze zkontrolovat
pozastavením videa, pokud chceš.
Vidíme, že pravděpodobnost
dostat výsledek nula je Phi8 tentokrát, a zde je vektor kvantového stavu,
který vznikne podmíněně
na dostat tento výsledek.
A pravděpodobnost dostat
výsledek jedna je tři osminy, v tom případě toto je
náš vektor kvantového stavu.
Přesně stejnou metodu lze použít v případě, že máš více než dva systémy a měříš jejich libovolnou vlastní podmnožinu.
WEBVTT
A v obsahu učebnice k této lekci je příklad,
který si můžeš prohlédnout, pokud tě zajímá.
Stručně řečeno, vždy můžeme rozdělit systémy do dvou oddělených skupin: ty, které jsou měřeny,
a ty, které nejsou.
A jakmile to uděláme, spoléháme na metodu,
kterou jsem právě popsal, a tak fungují měření pro více kvantových systémů.
A nyní nakonec přejdeme k unitárním
operacím na více systémech.
Použijeme stejnou základní myšlenku, že více systémů lze považovat za jediné složené systémy.
Dospíváme k závěru, co vidíš
napsané zde na obrazovce: kvantové operace na složených systémech jsou reprezentovány unitárními maticemi,
stejně jako pro jednotlivé systémy, a konkrétně řádky a sloupce těchto unitárních matic odpovídají kartézskému součinu
množin klasických stavů libovolné kolekce
systémů, o které mluvíme.
Například, pokud máme systém X,
jehož klasické stavy jsou jedna, dva a tři, a Y je qubit,
pak matice, kterou vidíš právě zde, je příkladem unitární matice, která reprezentuje
operaci na páru XY.
Detaily toho, jak pořadí kartézských součinů
funguje, jak jsme diskutovali dříve, ve skutečnosti nezáleží pro
účel tohoto příkladu, je to prostě matice 6×6,
která se náhodou je unitární.
Není na ní nic zvláštního, i když je sestavena z
pár důležitých matic.
Jde o to, že bys mohl
vybrat libovolnou unitární matici 6×6 a ta by reprezentovala
unitární operaci na XY.
Pokud aplikujeme kolekci
unitárních operací nezávisle každou na vlastním systému, pak jejich společný účinek
na složený systém je
dán tenzorové součinem.
A zde na obrazovce vidíš přesnější
vyjádření tohoto faktu.
Pokud jsou naše unitární operace popsány unitárními maticemi U1 až Un, jednou pro každý z našich systémů,
pak kombinovaný účinek
na složený systém je dán tenzorové
součinem U1 až Un.
Opět, podobně jako jsme měli v pravděpodobnostním kontextu, důležitý příklad je, že
aplikujeme nějakou unitární operaci
U na systém X a nic
neuděláme na jiném systému Y.
Operace na XY, kterou dostaneme, je U tenzorovaný s maticí identity.
Matice identity
popisuje nedělání ničeho s Y.
Někdy je užitečné explicitně napsat, že tato matice identity
odpovídá systému Y, aby vzorce byly jasnější.
A jednou možností je
dát matici identity dolní index takto, který indikuje systém, na který působí.
Když je to dostatečně jasné, obvykle se
neobtěžujeme s dolním indexem, ale když se věci stávají složitějšími, může být velmi užitečný.
A také lze uvažovat
o symetrickém případě, kde se na Y aplikuje nějaká unitární
operace V a na X se nic nedělá,
a tentokrát výsledná
unitární operace na XY je reprezentována tímto
tenzorové součinem zde.
A opět, dolní index na
maticí identity lze přidat, pokud to pomáhá.
Zde je pár konkrétních příkladů.
Pokud jsou X a Y qubity a
provedeme Hadamard operaci na X a neuděláme nic s Y, dostaneme matici, kterou vidíš právě zde.
Pokud naopak provedeme Hadamard operaci na Y a neuděláme nic s X, pořadí tenzorového
součinu se obrátí.
A takže dostaneme matici,
kterou vidíš právě zde.
Ne každou unitární operaci
na složeném systému lze vyjádřit jako tenzorový součin.
Pokud máme tenzorový součin,
pak máme nezávislost.
A existují docela
základní příklady operací, které rozhodně
nepůsobí nezávisle na více systémech.
Například, pokud X a Y mají
stejnou množinu klasických stavů, která může být libovolná
množina klasických stavů sigma,
pak lze uvažovat o
operaci prohození na páru XY.
Tato operace nemění pořadí dvou systémů, stále máme X
vlevo a Y vpravo, ale spíše reprezentuje
prohození obsahu
dvou systémů. Zde vidíš, že to je vyjádřeno
ve formě rovnice, kde máme tenzorový
součin dvou kvantových stavů.
Jiný způsob, jak to zapsat, je jako
matice, jak vidíme právě zde.
Způsob, jak o tomto popisu přemýšlet, je, že říká, co se stane se standardními bázovými vektory.
A jakmile víme, co se stane
se standardními bázovými vektory, víme, co se stane s
libovolnými kvantovými stavy ze linearity,
což ve skutečnosti platí i pro
tento výraz právě zde.
Takže tato konkrétní operace zde je zároveň deterministická operace i unitární operace.
Pokud jsou X a Y qubity, například, dostaneme tuto maticovou
reprezentaci právě zde.
Zde je zajímavé propojení
mezi operací prohození a čtyřmi Bellovými stavy, které jsou zobrazeny zde
pro přehlednost.
Operace prohození nechá
první tři z nich beze změny, ale dá minus znaménko
před stav Psi minus,
WEBVTT
takže na tomto je
něco zvláštního.
Tyto rovnice lze zkontrolovat přímo pohledem na tyto vektory a uvažováním o tom, co se stane
se standardními bázovými stavy.
Prohození dvou klasických stavů pro první tři Bellovy
stavy nic neudělá, dostaneme stejný stav, se kterým jsme začali.
Ve čtvrtém případě však se minus znaménko efektivně
přesouvá z jednoho členu na druhý, když provedeme prohození klasických stavů,
a to je ekvivalentní vynásobení vektoru minus jednou.
Takže provádění operace prohození jaksi vytahuje minus znaménko
z tohoto čtvrtého Bellova stavu.
O těchto rovnicích budeme mít
ještě co říct dále, ale nyní přejdeme
k jinému druhu operace, která je řízená operace.
Budeme předpokládat, že X je qubit a Y je libovolný systém.
Pokud U je unitární operace na Y, pak řízená operace U na XY je operace, která je
vyjádřena právě zde.
Nejprve pomocí Diracovy notace a pak pomocí tzv. blokové matice, kde si jednoduše představíš, že vyplníš tuto větší matici
menšími, kde tato nula opravdu reprezentuje matice
vyplněné nulami.
Takže každý z těchto čtyř bloků reprezentuje matici s
počtem řádků a sloupců, které odpovídají počtu
klasických stavů Y.
Myšlenka řízené operace, se kterou jsme se již setkali
v klasickém kontextu při diskuzi o
controlled-NOT operaci,
je taková, že pokud je X nastaveno na nulu,
pak se s Y nic nestane.
Ale pokud je X nastaveno na jednu,
pak se na Y aplikuje U.
Takže X se nazývá řídicí qubit a Y se nazývá cílový systém, který obecně
nemusí být qubit.
Pro konkrétní příklad,
který jsem právě zmínil, máme controlled-NOT operaci.
Pokud je první qubit nastaven
na nulu, nic se nestane. A pokud je první qubit nastaven na jednu, pak se provede operace NOT, nebo ekvivalentně,
operace sigma X se aplikuje
na druhý qubit.
A zde je její maticová reprezentace.
Mluvíme zde o dvou qubitech, takže bychom stejně tak mohli
rozhodnout, že druhý qubit je řídicí a
první je cíl.
Abychom popsali tuto operaci, jednoduše prohodíme pořadí
v tenzorové součinu a výsledkem je matice,
kterou vidíš právě zde.
Pokud místo controlled-NOT operace uvažujeme řízenou sigma
Z nebo controlled Z operaci.
Dostaneme tuto maticovou
reprezentaci právě zde. A pro tuto nezáleží ve skutečnosti na tom,
který je řídicí a který je cíl.
Dostaneme stejný výsledek v obou případech.
Můžeme jít dál a uvažovat o řízené operaci prohození.
A zde mluvíme
o prohození dvou qubitů, takže skončíme se třemi qubity, když zahrneme řídicí qubit.
Každá maticová reprezentace
vypadá takto.
Je to docela speciální operace a je známá jako Fredkinova operace, nebo běžněji Fredkin gate.
Když o tom uvažujeme
jako o gate v circuit, budeme o circuits mluvit v příští lekci.
Poslední příklad je řízená,
controlled-NOT operace, která je opět
operací na třech qubitech.
A zde je její maticová reprezentace. Tato operace je mnohem lépe
známa jako Toffliho operace nebo Toffoli gate.
Budeme ji dále diskutovat
a uvidíme, proč jak ona, tak Fredkin gate jsou velmi důležité
operace v pozdější lekci.
A to je konec druhé lekce. V této lekci jsme diskutovali, jak kvantová informace funguje pro více systémů.
Doufám, že se ke mně brzy přidáš
na třetí lekci, která je o kvantových circuits,
protokolech a hrách.
Nashledanou do té doby.